welcome back and thanks for joining me  today if we take a happy little Zero  Dimensional point and move it one unit  to the right  we get a one-dimensional line move that  line down by one unit  and we get a big friendly  two-dimensional Square to get a 3D shape  we want to move Mr square one unit out  of the board but we draw that third  dimension as a diagonal shift because we  can't draw it perpendicular  and we get a cube  so a diagonal shift perpendicular to  this one may send Mr Cube to the fourth  dimension I've drawn a cube diagonally  shifted and I'm connecting up all the  points to draw a 4D hypercube or at  least a drawing of one done by a 3D  creature on a 2d chalkboard I might miss  some lines but that's okay no mistakes  in math just happy accidents